herr merz wir sitzen hier im oval office
in berlin hier hat heute nacht bild 16
stunden lang über die us-wahl berichtet
waren sie eigentlich schon mal in
washington ja man war das muss ich lange
nachdenken das war als george bush vater
vizepräsident war als ob ich mal eine
eine nachhaltige an 100 90er jahre ein
besuch im oval office gemacht in
washington und eine auch eine führung
durchs haus
ja hat sie das überrascht was heute
nacht was wir heute morgen erlebt haben
quasi einen war patin den usa nein
offengestanden der schäfer nicht denn
wir haben das ja erwarten können auch
erwarten müssen dass es sehr eng wird
dass aufgrund der sehr hohen zahl der
briefwahl auch lange gezählt wird und
dass möglicherweise auch um diese
auszählung ein juristischer konflikt
noch einmal entbrennt und insofern habe
ich gestern abend ich bin gestern abend
normal schlafen gegangen etwas später
als sonst weil ich noch einen besucher
hatte aber dann bin ich heute morgen
nicht allzu früh aufgestanden haben sie
die daumen gedrückt
ich finde wir sollten uns aus deutscher
sicht heraus halten mit öffentlichen
empfehlungen und auch mit öffentlichen
meinungen werden und der bessere
präsident wäre ich finde der respekt vor
den wählerinnen und wählern in amerika
gebietet ist dass wir das mit
zurückhaltung aber mit natürlich auch
großem interesse beobachten wir erleben
jetzt einen richtigen nervenschlacht ums
weiße haus donald trump sagt er ist der
sieger der beiden sagt wir müssen noch
ein bisschen warten und fühlt sich als
der heimliche sieger wie gefährlich ist
so eine patt situation so ein
machtvakuum für die usa für die ganze
welt
wir müssen vielleicht auch unseren
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer noch mal
kurz erläutern dass dieses wahlsystem
anders ist als bei uns es gibt in
amerika keine landeswahlleiter und es
gibt auch kein bundeswahlleiter der ein
vorläufiges endergebnis fest stellt und
dann erst die politischen parteien ihre
kommentare dazu abgeben
jeder start in amerika kann sein eigenes
wahlrecht machen es gibt bestimmte
formalitäten die müssen eingehalten
werden aber wie gewählt wird wie gezählt
wird
das ist alles sache der einzelstaaten
und das sind jetzt 50 an der zahl
und die müssen dann alle irgendwann die
zahlen zusammen bringen und wie gesagt
dann gibt es niemanden der das offiziell
feststellt sondern es wird so öffentlich
ausgezählt wie wir es im augenblick
erleben es gibt die präsidentin der sagt
jetzt ist der wahltag vorbei jetzt
sozusagen muss zählen was bis heute
ausgezählt wurden es gibt den
herausforderer sagt wir müssen alles
aussehen und zwar bis zum ende also wer
hat recht von den beiden das wird im
zweifel dann wieder einmal so wie schon
vor einigen jahren noch der supreme
court entscheiden die gerichte werden ja
jetzt schon angerufen und beide befinden
sich da in einem offenen dissens
miteinander wie gezählt werden muss und
was noch gezählt werden darf also
überlassen was dann auch mal den beiden
und auch davon deutschland ratschläge
unerwünscht wie lange glauben sie wird
diese hängepartie dieses machtvakuum
jetzt dauern es kann sein dass das noch
einige stunden dauert wahrscheinlich
wird das dann irgendwann nach deutscher
zeit heute abend vielleicht heute nacht
entschieden werden das sind jetzt noch
sechs staaten die nicht zuende
ausgezählt sind aber warten wir es ab
wir werden noch ein bisschen geduld
haben das heißt sie glauben morgen früh
nach deutscher zeit haben wir klarheit
wäre der nächste us-präsident also ich
ich ich ich glaube da nichts und ich
habe eine vermutung wenn es zu ende sein
wird und sagen ja meine vermutung ist
dass wir es heute nacht oder spätestens
morgen früh wissen aber das ist auch
nicht sicher es kann sein dass es noch
einmal eine größere juristische schlacht
gibt als george bush sohn kandidiert hat
und elgar der gegenkandidat war an haben
die ausstellungen in florida bis zum
übernächsten tag gedauert und dann hat
der supreme court das gestoppt und ein
ergebnis festgestellt wäre es dann wird
wen erleben wir morgen früher mehr in
deutschland wieder aufwachen als den
präsidenten den alten oder den 9
also im augenblick spricht aus meiner
sicht mehr dafür dass trump im amt
bleibt als das beiden ins amt kommt aber
auch da sind überraschungen möglich wäre
so eine hängepartie in deutschland
eigentlich auch denkbar nach der
nächsten bundestagswahl
wir zählen in deutschland anders unsere
formalitäten sind strenger wir haben ein
einheitliches wahlrecht und wahlsystem
in der bundesrepublik deutschland allen
bundesländern
es gibt hier eine sehr enge kooperation
zwischen den wahlämtern und dem
bundeswahlleiter
nein das wäre in deutschland so nicht
möglich wir könnten in deutschland ein
parlament haben mit unklaren mehrheiten
aber wir werden ja kein bundeskanzler
direkt durch die bevölkerung durch die
wählerinnen und wähler wir wählen einen
bundestag und der bundeskanzler die
bundeskanzlerin wird dann im deutschen
bundestag gewählt also nicht
vergleichbar wir haben diese
persönlichkeit vor allem nicht wie
gefährlich ist die situation die wir
jetzt in den usa erleben denn für unser
land
ich beobachte schon seit vielen jahren
dieses auseinanderdriften der land auch
diese spaltung amerikas und das was sie
in der politik erleben ist ja nur 1 1
ein spiegelbild auch des zustandes der
amerikanischen gesellschaft eigentlich
schon seit mehreren jahren vielleicht
sogar zwei jahrzehnten andauernd dass es
hier eine solche spaltung gibt nehmen
sie nur mal die tea party bewegung die
ja nun wirklich sehr konservativ
teilweise rechts und rechtsradikal ist
nehmen sie die demokratische partei die
so eine außenstehende organisation nicht
hat die sich aber selbst sehr stark nach
links hin entwickelt hat zum teil sogar
radikalisiert hat
während centers hat vor vier jahren mit
dem anspruch ein demokratischer
sozialist zu sein fasst die nominierung
der demokratischen partei bekommen also
amerika hat auf beiden seiten des
politischen spektrums eine gewisse
radikalisierung in den letzten jahren
erlebt und das lähmt dieses land macht
politische entscheidungen extrem
schwierig und macht amerika damit auch
für seine partner zunehmend
unkalkulierbar und das ist etwas was wir
in deutschland einfach zur kenntnis
nehmen müssen wir können das nicht
ändern aber wir müssen daraus
schlussfolgern sie wären meine
schlussfolgerung ist schon seit langer
zeit dass wir uns eben nicht mehr auf
diese rolle amerikas alleine stützen
können dass amerika die globale
ordnungsmacht ist die welt ordnungsmacht
die auch für unsere sicherheit mit sorgt
dieser schutzschirm amerikas über europa
ist in diesem umfang nicht mehr da wie
gehabt haben das heißt ihr euch folgen
das bedeutet aber wir müssen was das
thema 2% zum beispiel an gerüsten haben
deutlich erhöhen mann hat in einem die
deutsche politik erklärt zwar immer
wieder nicht nur die deutsche auch die
europäische wir müssen uns unabhängiger
von amerika machen aber richtig
passieren tut eigentlich nichts
die bundeskanzlerin hat schon nach ihrer
ersten begegnung mit donald trump auf
einer der großen internationalen
konferenzen vor drei jahren
offensichtlich auch unter dem eindruck
stehen dieser ersten begegnung gesagt
wir deutschen und wir europäer müssen
jetzt hat sie sich ausgedrückt unser
schicksal ein stück weit selbst in die
hand nehmen und das ist exakt meine
meinung aber wehranlage dazu können wir
möchten dass zum ganzen gruppe
deswegen sei in der jetzigen zeitpunkt
nicht doch da kann ich nur die
bundeskanzlerin wir sind nicht in der
lage uns selbst weber teil im augenblick
nicht in der lage uns unabhängig von den
vereinigten staaten von amerika zu
verteidigen wir sind auch nicht in der
lage zum beispiel die massiven angriffe
auf unsere daten systeme auf unsere
rechenzentren ohne die audio
internationale terrorismus das was wir
auch im mittleren osten an entwicklungen
sehen
das ist vor unserer haustür und das
heißt im klartext deutschland und auch
europa müssen sehr viel mehr
verantwortung auch für die sicherheit im
eigenen territorium über trotzdem wird
amerika von vielen deutschen
mittlerweile sehr sehr kritisch gesehen
auch von deutschen politikern es gab ja
eine massive heben in den letzten jahren
gegenüber tollen job ist gab die großen
auch offen vorgetragenen wünsche dass
donald trump nicht mehr im weissen haus
sitzen soll
ist das nicht eine ein zwiespalt ist das
nicht auch janusköpfig was wir da machen
einerseits immer amerika zu kritisieren
mit häme über dieses land zu sprechen
andererseits aber gar nicht selbst in
der lage zu sein uns selbst
beispielsweise verteidigen zu können
oder wichtige geopolitische fragen auch
selbst alleine lösen zu können ohne
amerika
diese haltung hat zentralen der
deutschen bevölkerung immer gegeben
ich erinnere nur an den besuch von
george bush also dem 41 präsidenten in
deutschland zu beginn seiner amtszeit in
krefeld und in anderen orten zum
höhepunkt der nachrüstungsdebatte da hat
es eine solche frontstellung gegen
amerika und eine solche anti
amerikanische stimmung in teilen der
bevölkerung auch gegeben meine
wahrnehmung ist es gibt in großen teilen
der deutschen bevölkerung immer noch
viel zuneigung zu amerika immer noch
viel verständnis für dieses land nicht
für diesen präsidenten aber wohl für
dieses land und meine persönliche
auffassung ist amerika ist trotz trump
immer noch ein wichtiger partner für
europa auch für deutschland umgekehrt
wir haben in amerika ein hohes ansehen
jedes mal wenn ich in amerika bin bin
ich erstaunt darüber wie nach wie vor
groß das ansehen der deutschen auch der
europäer
mehr noch der deutschen in amerika ist
und wir sind auch nach wie vor partner
auch wenn wir natürlich zunehmend auch
ökonomisch konkurrenten sind wenn sie
sagen trotzdem hätten sie sich joe biden
als präsident gewünscht
ja noch mal ich finde wir sollten uns
aus der deutschen politik mit solchen
wünschen und solchen aufforderungen oder
solchen einmischungen in die inneren
angelegenheiten dieses landes
zurückhaltend
mir macht sorge die zunehmende
dysfunktional i tät des amerikanischen
aber es war eine einrichtung sind sie
sagen ich bin für den oder für den das
ist ja einfach wissen sie und dann muss
morgen eine deutsche bundesregierung mit
diesem präsidenten wieder arbeit mit
einem kanzler märz nein ich nicht es
geht nicht um meine person sondern es
geht einfach darum dass wir auch den
respekt vor wahlentscheidungen in
amerika nicht verlieren und uns nicht
mit wünschen dass die politik auch die
internationale kollekten politik ist
kein wunschkonzert so wir müssen mit dem
gewählten regierungen und
staatsoberhäuptern reden und arbeiten
die vom volk gewählt sind und amerika
ist eine demokratie eine schwieriger
demokratie an zum teil dysfunktional
demokratie aber diese entscheidung
treffen die amerikanischen wählerinnen
und wähler und nicht deutsche politiker
und auch nicht deutscher daran ist wie
gut könnte ein bundeskanzler friedrich
merz mit einem us präsidenten donald
trump zusammenarbeiten
ich habe viel erfahrung im umgang mit
amerikanischen gesprächspartnern
amerikanischen politikern ich bin nun
beruflich auch sehr viel in amerika
gewesen ich weiß wie die amerikaner
ticken wir kämen schon klar aber aus
einer position des selbstbewusstseins
heraus und einer position der stärke und
einer position der schwäche
sie haben vor vier jahren als chef der
atlantik brücke nach der wahl von donald
trump zum präsidenten 1 kommentar für
bild geschrieben und darin haben sie ich
zitiere auch kritisieren jetzt kommt
dass die tat dass diese wahl in
anführungsstrichen ein der vorläufige
höhepunkt einer völligen entgleisung der
politischen kultur über die letzten
jahre gewesen ist wo stehen wir heute
ist es noch schlimmer geworden
naja es ist jedenfalls nicht besser
geworden nicht wir haben ein wir haben
ein sprachgebrauch in amerika erlebt
eine missachtung der institutionen auch
eine gegenseitige herabwürdigung im
wahlkampf die würde ich nicht gerne
übertragen auf deutschland ich finde wir
können gerade wenn wir solche
fernsehbilder sehen wie aus den letzten
tagen doch mit einigem stolz sagen dass
unsere institution funktionieren wir
aber auch sagen müssen
diesen respekt müssen wir alle
miteinander behalten und wir sollten
auch respektvoll miteinander umgehen
auch wenn wir in die nächste
bundestagswahl gehen auch wenn es
politische gegner sind wir sind gegner
und nicht feinde wenn man sie als als
sauerland bezeichnet wie hart trifft sie
das
auch da hat das halbe sauerland laut
drüber gelacht und ich nehme es ehrlich
gesagt auch nicht ernst weil ich eine
ganz andere grundhaltung auch gegenüber
institutionen auch gegenüber politischen
gegnern habe ich verachte sie nicht ich
bringe sie nicht in misskredit und ich
finde wir haben alle den auftrag unsere
institutionen auch zu schützen vor denen
die unsere demokratie angreifen was sind
die lehren aus dem us wahlkampf aus der
situation die wir heute tagsüber jetzt
auch sehen die ganze nacht
wahrscheinlich sehen werden für den
bundestagswahlkampf im nächsten jahr
also meine schlussfolgerung ist relativ
einfach gehen wir anständig miteinander
um
auch wenn wir unterschiedlicher meinung
sind tragen wir politische differenzen
offen aus aber in der sache klar und den
persönlichen umgang einfach anständig
miteinander so wenn wir das beherzigen
dann wird auch unsere demokratie
weiterhin von einer großen mehrzahl der
bevölkerung in deutschland geschätzt und
unterstützt wird friedrich merz heute in
einem jahr im oval office in washington
gewesen sein das ist ehrlich gesagt eine
frage mit der sie sich vielleicht
beschäftigen ich beschäftige mich damit
nicht ich beschäftige mich im augenblick
damit meine chancen zu verbessern weiter
zu verbessern
parteivorsitzender der cdu zu werden und
das ist das datum am 16 januar sind
diese chancen aus ihrer sicht die sind
aus meiner sicht gut und sie sind seit
gestern noch einmal ein bisschen besser
geworden ich werde jetzt von zwei großen
vereinigungen der cdu unterstützt von
der wirtschafts und mittelstands union
und von der jungen union und gerade das
letztere ist mir besonders wichtig dass
ich von der jungen generation und
unserer jugend organisation eine so
große unterstützung bekomme das freut
mich das ehrt mich auch aber das spornt
mich auch an
man wirft ihnen vor genau wie man donald
trump auch für wirft die cdu zu spalten
ist das richtig diesen vorwurf den den
lasse ich nicht auf mir sitzen
im gegenteil ich versuche die cdu
inhaltlich zu profilieren und versuchen
uns gemeinsam auch in ein gutes wahljahr
2021 zu führen wir sind ihre chancen auf
dem wahlparteitag dann am 16 ja noch mal
aus meiner sicht sind sie zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt gut und sie
haben sich durch den entscheid der
jungen union
dann noch einmal verbessert ich bin sehr
zuversichtlich wir sind bild und wie ihr
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren